MELIKA GOLKARAM:
Hello, everyone.
I hope you've had a
great Google Next so far.
And thank you so much for
attending this session.
My name is Melika Golkaram.
I'm a media specialist customer
engineer from Google Cloud.
And today, I have the pleasure
to co-present this session
with two industry experts,
Jeff Webb, a principal solution
design architect from
Sky, and Moore Macauley.
He's a director of
product from Harmonic.
So what are we hearing
in this session?
Well, I think it's
useful for all of us
to go a little bit
back and look at what's
happened in the industry, how
things have shifted and changed
until we've got to this
point, and go to 2018 and 2019
and see what Google Cloud
has done for media customers
to help them achieve
their targets
and implement their
interesting projects.
And then I'll ask Jeff
to come up the stage
and take us through
their interesting journey
of designing and deploying a
future-proof sports streaming
platform.
And then, Moore is
going to give us
a different angle of how
they implement it there,
basically stream processing
applications on top
of containers to help Sky
in this wonderful project.
So this is really
interesting for all of us.
Today, we are all so used
to get any sort of content
with great quality on
any device in a way
that we all forget that this
industry is actually not
that old.
If you look at 2005
when, for the first time,
YouTube was launched
as, basically,
the biggest streaming
platform in the world.
10 years down the line,
things shifted and changed
in every different way.
Streaming protocols, transcoding
formats, infrastructure grew.
Big data-- everything
changed so rapidly
that 10 years down
the line, we see
a 4% fall from the
traditional TV viewership.
And that figure lends itself
into a 74% increase in content
viewership on YouTube.
So this figure looks a little
bit odd, because 4% versus 74%.
Part of it is because
the overall viewership
of content on traditional
TV was a huge number.
So when you lend
it into YouTube,
it becomes a really big factor.
But the other part was
that people overall
started to watch content a
lot more than they used to
before, because obviously, you
could find any sort of niche
content you wouldn't be able
to find on TV on YouTube.
Three years later--
this is interesting--
the overall viewership
of content on streaming
platforms--
not only YouTube,
but everywhere--
witnessed a 35%
increase year on year.
And then today,
where we're standing,
people are consuming one
billion hours of content
only on YouTube.
That's a massive number.
So that makes us hopeful
that for the next five years,
the profit that gets shifted
away from traditional TV
platforms, IPTV, cable TV--
and this $30 billion
profit will be
spent on online TV platforms.
So that will take
us to 2025, where
half of the viewers
of the age of below 32
will never actually see a
subscription on traditional TV
platforms.
And that will take
the consumption
of media on internet to
25% of the world data.
So we know that things
have changed so much.
We're really proud to be
standing in this moment.
But we want to see
if Cloud is going
to be the next big
wave of disruption
into the media and tech
industry, at the same time.
So let's see why Cloud
matters in this industry.
So problem number one of
every technology company
is the speed to delivery.
If you're a media company,
your problem is a lot bigger.
Why?
You're acquiring a lot
of content from studios,
from sports organizations--
this massive amount of money
you're spending.
And you want to make sure that
you're launching the service
right on time, you
are actually providing
any sort of necessary
infrastructure
without having to worry about
infrastructure planning.
And the other problem
about media industry
is that it's not only
about applications.
It's also about the delivery
of media across the world.
So you need to make sure
that your content gets
encoded, transcoded,
is being sent
across the world
with minimum delay.
The other problem
is that when you
work in a really
fast environment,
you need to be sure
that you're scaling,
but you're not
constantly calculating
and you're not being stingy
with your infrastructure,
because you want to make
sure your users are not
getting delays, or that you
wouldn't lose your viewers
to your competition.
A very good example of
that is news content.
So if you lose one or two
minutes of content viewership,
on a kind of delivery
on your network,
then people would just
go to your competition.
And then you're using millions
of dollars of ads for something
pretty plain and simple.
So with Cloud, you can
actually do this scalability
pretty fast.
And then you just shut
down your instances.
And after that,
you didn't really
have to worry about a
bunch of annoying servers
in your infrastructure.
Then again, you can have any
sort of analytics you want.
You can think about what you
want to do with it later.
You can be super
generous with your data.
And you can also
use that data later,
once you figure out what
data set is important for you
to have intelligent
decision-making with machine
learning.
And machine learning is
infrastructure demanding.
So with Cloud, you can
actually fix that problem.
And then the sweet story
of studio requirements.
So if you're a
content distributor
and you work with multiple
different studios, each of them
comes to you with
a massive contract
of different requirements
for your infrastructure.
And if you work with
a cloud provider,
you really don't have to worry
about at least the basics
of these requirements.
With all said and
done, we still think
hybrid solutions
are going to stay
with media industry for a
while from now, because you
have your transcoders,
encoders on premise.
And you want to
make sure that you
are keeping this infrastructure,
but burst into cloud
whenever it's needed.
And here we are.
We are in Google
Cloud infrastructure.
When you look at
that map, you really
shouldn't see a lot of
colorful dots and fibers--
even though it's entertaining
to look at it that way, too.
But you should
actually look at this
as a representation
of six Google services
that have more than one
billion subscribers.
All these services
are sending traffic
securely with a
lot of scalability
through this network, through
these points of presence.
And Cloud is using very
much the same infrastructure
that YouTube, Gmail, Maps,
and those services are using.
Over the past three years,
we have spent $20 billion
on infrastructure to maintain
and expand our network.
We have invested in
13 sub-sea cables.
We've launched in 18 different
regions, 55 zones, 134 network
edges, and 90 CDN locations,
plus 73 interconnect locations.
We recently launched
in Switzerland.
And we are launching in
Indonesia and in Japan
for the second time.
But we know success
doesn't come from wealth.
What made Google
Google is technology.
So if you look at different
layers of technology,
here, you see we
build our own chips.
We build our own hardware.
We build our own data centers.
We maintain it.
We invented Kubernetes.
All of our services,
across the board,
use Kubernetes is to
scale fast and easily.
We have multiple
layers of identity
to control access
to our platform.
If you look at how much content
is being stored and uploaded
in YouTube, you will see
storage is not an issue
that we would worry about-- and
the security around it, either.
We talked about our
backbone, but it's sitting
on top of everything else.
And the operational
and security of devices
is something that our SREs are
paying attention to every day.
So how would your service
look like, ultimately?
If you're a kind of
visual studio company
and you have people
sitting in Los Angeles,
in London, different
parts of the world,
you have content stored
in multiple locations,
you want to make
sure that you can
do your editing on
the device that is not
present in your data center,
but gives you the illusion
of having it at your vicinity.
If you are a live sports
company like Jeff is,
you basically want to make
sure that your content is
being distributed around
the world without any delay.
If you are a telco and
you've acquired other telcos
and you are distributing
to multiple locations,
you want to make sure that
your studio rights are
being obeyed, basically.
And finally, when you look
at the amount of storage
you will be needing,
you really don't
want to worry about
how much content
is being stored every day.
So with Google Cloud,
we're giving you
a huge amount of infrastructure
to scale your services.
We give you containers,
Kubernetes app deployment
services where you can deploy
with a lot of scalability
and reach your goals.
We give you an 11-9
durable storage--
different classes, but instant
access across the board
to store your content.
Your network is basically a
global network that is well
connected with our fiber.
And your services
are going to be
distributed in different
virtual private networks.
But because they're within
Google infrastructure,
the security is
complied and the content
is being encrypted at
rest and at transit.
We also give you a lot
of big data and machine
learning capabilities to
sit on top of your services,
to give you intelligent
ideas about how you can push
for better business
decisions and for maintaining
your customers on your platform.
This picture always
cracks me up.
In 2010, this
picture went online.
And it drove the whole
internet crazy about whether it
was Tom Hanks or Bill Murray.
What do you think?
Thank you.
Yes, it's Bill Murray.
The whole point is,
with the whole hype
about cloud these
days, there is so much
similarity between
cloud platforms
that people sometimes
get confused
about what would be the best
decision for their own business
idea.
And we think there
are certain things
in Google Cloud that shines
among all other services.
We are investing a lot
in hybrid approaches.
Cloud storage is a
very special service,
especially when
it comes to media.
We give you a metadata
caching, redundancy,
duplication across the board.
It's multi-regional.
And regardless of
what class of storage
you put your content on, it's
always instant accessibility.
Our CDN is very
easy to configure.
So it's literally just
putting a tick at a box,
and then content gets
cached everywhere.
We have a new approach
to machine learning.
We use Auto ML, which gives
you access to our models.
But you can train it
with your own data.
So you can get rid of a
lot of unnecessary labels
that you would get
from a generic model.
And the network that we
talked about several times--
it helps you distribute
your content a lot faster.
2018-- it was
interesting for us.
We launched in eight
new regions and we
took Dedicated and
Partner Interconnect
to general availability.
With rendering, we rewrote
the whole Zync platform.
And it's available on
Google infrastructure,
and provides up to
48,000 cores to editors,
and individual editors.
We released a live
machine learning service
for video analysis in real time.
We released a lot of features
for metadata enrichment,
and also for monetization, like
video Auto ML, object tracking,
and stuff like that.
In terms of OTT, AVATA, which
is our end-to-end platform,
launched in Europe.
And our CVN, in terms
of media, went on GA.
And Cloud armor was launched
to protect your service.
And we are doing a lot
of interesting stuff
with archiving.
So tape digitization as a
part of bigger Google services
and art and culture
helps our customers
that have valuable content to
digitize those tapes with very
little money and then use
machine learning to enrich
the metadata for those assets.
And what's coming in 2019?
We are launching five new
sea cables across the board.
Hybrid platforms are going
to stay as our highest
priority this year.
So that will help you
work with your streaming
services, your different
types of-- if you have machine
learning stuff on premise,
and a lot of different aspects
of hybrid workflows
or in different cloud
providers with one control plane
and the same set of APIs that
are basically industry standards
like Kubernetes, for example.
We are replacing
our MPAA licensing
with TPN, which covers a lot
more broadcasters and content
owners.
That will be available on
major GCP infrastructure.
And we are doing a lot
of CDN enhancements.
We are working on
providing media
APIs for encoding,
transcoding, and ad insertion.
We are releasing a
neutral rendering
platform called OpenCue.
That's independent of any
specific software, like Zync.
And we are working
on other AI services
to go to general availability.
And something very interesting
is about edge TPUs--
that you will be able to
download the model on a device
offline and the device
will do the analysis
and send the results
to the cloud.
So with that, I'm going to ask
Jeff to come up to the stage
and take us through their
interesting story, which
is very inspirational.
JEFF WEBB: I'm going to talk
over the next 20 minutes
about live sports in the cloud.
We've been doing it for
a long time on premise.
And there's lots of
opportunities in the cloud.
So my name's Jeff Webb.
I'm principal
streaming architect.
I'm from Sky UK,
hence the accent.
So what I'm going to
talk about is about Sky.
So for those not familiar with
who we are, go through that.
Believe in better streaming,
which is part of our ethos.
Success formula for delivering
live streaming service.
So what does that make?
Software Defined
Streaming-- this
is our concept for the
next generation platform.
How Cloud benefits, and
comparison of on-premise.
We have a thing called
single channel fault
domain, which is really kind of
where the key innovation comes
in.
And I'm going to
show you what happens
when something goes wrong.
So about Sky-- we have 23.6
million customers in Europe.
And we operate in seven
European countries.
We're very proud, now, to be
part of the Comcast family.
So that acquisition went
through a few months ago.
Sky Q, which is our
setup box proposition
in Europe-- and that's
in 5.5 million homes.
That's up from 3.4
million last year.
We're increasing investment
in original drama,
for a 25% increase
over last year.
And very interestingly, if
you produce really good drama,
then more customers
will watch it.
So you can see viewing has more
than doubled in the last three
years.
Put this up here because this
is something else, as well.
I'm really proud to be part of
a socially responsible company.
So we have things
like Sky Ocean Rescue.
And you might have seen things
across the internet-- things
about trying to save the oceans.
There's a lot of plastic that
we throw away and ends up
in the animals and
the whales and things.
And it's not a good thing.
So believe in better streaming.
Going to take you through a
little journey of the last 10
years.
I myself have been
at Sky for 14 years.
I've been in the
streaming team since 2009.
So over that 10-year
period, we've
gone through three
different generations.
We started off, as
most broadcasters
did, in 2009 when Apple
announced the HLS spec.
We wanted to be able
to do live sports--
Premier League and things.
And so we did what
most broadcasters did
They went out to market,
went and did a comparison, go
through the RFI, RFP process,
bought some white boxes,
plugged them in in
the data center.
You had video in on one side.
You had video out
on the other side.
And customers were happy.
Fast forward several
years, business changes.
Customers want higher quality.
You've gone from standard
definition phones.
Now you've got retina
displays on your phones
and your tablets.
And so customers are expecting
to get a better quality.
Obviously, you've also got big
screens, smart TVs, and so on.
So we went to generation 2.
Problem with the first model is
that you go and you try and buy
the biggest box you can afford
because you want to maximize
your channel density.
So you put five channels
on this big box.
And this box cost
you like $20,000.
If you want to get more,
then you spend more.
That business model
is fine up until you
have to go and replace it.
So every few years, about
every three years or so,
you have to go through the
upgrade, refresh cycle.
And that's a very
expensive way of doing it.
In reality, as broadcaster,
all you need is the software.
The software is the
intellectual property.
So that's what we
did in generation 2.
We said, why would
I buy your server?
I just want your software.
We can run our own server,
as most enterprises do.
We run VMware.
So that's what we did.
We virtualized it.
And we've run that
platform for six years now.
And that's been very successful.
What I'm talking today about
is moving to the cloud,
specifically for
sports, because there's
a really great
opportunity for that.
So just to give
you some context,
what is the success formula
for delivering a live streaming
service?
This can be sports.
It can be anything.
Well, firstly, it
starts with content.
Leaving aside the technology,
customers in the pay TV
operator-- they want
to be entertained.
They want to watch the sports.
They want to watch the
"Game of Thrones" next week.
They want to watch Italian or
German football, and so on.
That is what they pay for.
That's part of the experience.
And so we shouldn't forget that.
At Sky, I'm part of what's
called software engineering.
Software engineering is
actually quite a lot of people.
In the building I'm
in, there's 800 or so
that are in software
engineering.
And these guys and
girls are very clever.
And they basically go
and write the software.
Now, unlike a lot
of other people,
we give the software
away for free.
So the network is
obviously key to this.
So if you own and
operate your own network,
then, obviously, you can
ensure that that last mile
connection, especially,
is, obviously, optimized.
In the UK, we offer
Sky Broadband,
which is our second-largest
broadband provider in the UK.
And this is now--
I think it's about
six million customers.
Sky Broadband is also
rolling out in Sky Italy
later this year.
Obviously, have lots
of CDNs, because we
have lots of traffic
and lots of customers--
which segues nicely
onto customers.
So here's what a Sky
Q box looks like.
We have, now, TVs that use Roku
and, obviously, mobile devices,
smart TVs, consoles, and so on.
Ultimately, if you take
content plus developers
plus network plus customers,
it all gives you quality.
Because lots of customers,
they'll want to do the thing,
watch the content
at the same time.
So next Monday is
a good example.
You'll have "Game of
Thrones" on there at 9 PM.
It's going to be simulcast
between US and Europe.
Customers want to watch
it on their devices.
They want to watch it
together, because it's
a social experience, just
like when you get Super
Bowl or Olympics and things.
And they want to watch it in HD
because that's what they want.
So software-defined streaming.
This is reimagining of
how we deliver and go.
We came up with this
interesting concept
called Streaming DevOps,
because we've been
doing streaming for 10 years.
And we've been
doing it very well,
and obviously, customers
are happy with that.
But we wanted to make it better.
And so it's been part
of software engineering.
We looked out and
asked our colleagues
and said, how can we take
what other teams within Sky
are doing from the DevOps world
and bring that into streaming?
So we created something.
We made it up.
It's called Streaming DevOps.
And really, it's four
things that come into it.
First is RAM resilience.
So as a broadcaster,
you're giving the customer
the experience.
In live sports, you can't
afford to have downtime
because if they've
missed the goal,
it's not going to come again.
They're going to have to watch
on the repeat or something.
So you want to try and
avoid that at all costs.
We came up with the Single
Channel Fault Domain concept.
I'll show you what that
is in a couple of slides.
And also, I'll talk,
I'll give you the example
of how it's self-healing.
So basically, if
you have a problem,
don't show the customer.
Hide the problem until
you've resolved it.
Channels must stay on air.
And that's critical.
Geographic resilience
is very key
because a simple
analogy would be,
if you've got one data center,
don't put all your channels
in one data center
because chances are,
one day, something will
go wrong and you'll
lose not just one channel,
but a whole bunch of channels.
So have two baskets.
Do exactly the same.
Make sure the baskets are
identical with your channels.
And you'll be a lot better.
In order to do that, you
need highly available
synchronized video streaming.
And that's what we'll
show a little bit later.
The second pillar is
around speed to market.
Melika touched on it earlier.
The problem with
enterprise is that you
have to go through
the procurement cycle.
If we order a server today,
six to eight weeks later,
the server will arrive,
it'll get plugged in.
It's too long.
How many football matches,
how many basketballs games
have you missed by then?
Well, quite a lot, especially
if it's March Madness.
Automatic pipeline-- so taking
some of the benefits of what's
going on in DevOps.
So the continuous integration,
continuous deployment.
I'm sure, obviously, a lot of
you Googlers and other people--
don't need to
explain what that is.
The third pillar
is observability.
We're dealing with video.
We're a TV company.
So when that "Game of Thrones"
episode is coming through,
you want to make sure that,
before it gets to the customer,
that it's actually good video
and good audio coming out.
Because if you had
a lip sync issue,
it's a bad customer experience.
So you want to make sure
that your monitoring
systems before you actually
get it to the customer
is actually good.
And doing that in an automated
way is the way to go.
Obviously, for
operations reasons,
you want to be able
to have centralized
logging and monitoring using
open-source tools like the ELK
Stack and also
real-time dashboards--
things like using Grafana
and Prometheus, as well.
So you can give
ops guys actually
what's going on right
now with customers
and see how the
platform is performing.
And the fourth one, really,
is actually the key one.
And the reason
why I'm here today
is talking about
transportability.
At the outset, we had
a desire, a principle
to make the platform agnostic.
So on premise, we run in VMware.
So now, we're taking it
into Google with GCP.
Just to mention there about GKE,
we're not doing GKE on premise,
but I just heard the
announcement yesterday
that it's coming.
So how does the cloud benefit
live sports streaming?
Fairly obvious one.
It shortens the
development cycle
because you're not having
to wait for infrastructure.
We can spin up, now,
channels in minutes.
So everything's pre-configured.
So if you take a
Formula One example,
those Grand Prixs are run, on
average, about every two weeks.
Sometimes every other week,
dependant on the geography.
But sometimes,
it's a bit longer.
But on Friday, they
have their practice.
Saturday, you have qualifying.
And Sunday, you have the race.
Each of those channels
must be consistently built.
So if I have the
Australian Grand Prix
and then, two weeks later, I
have the Singapore Grand Prix,
and then a week later, I have
the Bahrain Grand Prix, then
the actual channel configuration
itself is the same.
The only thing that's really
changed over those three events
is the time and, actually,
the content itself.
The way that I
deliver it to a client
is still the same end points.
When a customer presses
Play, it's still the same.
Each channel in
the configuration
must be built consistently.
We have a a YAML file,
another markup language.
It has all the configuration
parameters for channels.
So you would have things
like your A/B ladder.
You would have DRM types.
You'd have stream
formats and so on.
This is really
critical, because this
allows you to maintain
or become stateless.
So your channel configuration
can be stateless.
This is very necessary
for reasons of continuity
at the moment.
We wanted a platform
to be modular.
So, obviously, technology
changes from time to time.
Some smart people will go and
invent new codecs and things
for new devices and stuff.
Things will come along
and things will go away.
So you need it to be
modular so that you're not
locked into a
particular technology
when something much better can
come along and possibly even be
cheaper, as well.
Cost effective.
So, obviously, make sure that
you can do it cost effectively.
Speed to market--
fairly obvious.
End-to-end automation pipeline.
Do everything automatically.
Do not have engineers going
into graphical user interfaces,
manually putting
in configurations,
and pressing Apply.
We used to do that.
Not doing that anymore.
So increase reliability
and protection--
a Single Channel Fault Domain.
I'll show you that.
And a really interesting
thing that we're now
able to do in the cloud, because
it's much more cost effective,
is around A/B
multivariate testing.
So imagine being able to
have a Sky Sports channel.
Let's say it's Formula
One, because that's
on the next slide.
And that's the standard version.
Then what we have
is a B version of it
which is slightly different.
So you make the B version
available to some customers.
You try what it is
in the real world.
And you get feedback on
it, like you would do
going through a trials process.
This is video, so you
actually need to see it.
You need the data.
So it's quite key.
This new platform allows us
to maintain channel uptime.
So that's really critical.
Software upgrades is
a classic problem.
So in this diagram, I've
taken a layered approach.
My arm's not that big.
So other top, you've
got Sky clients.
You've got Sky Go,
Now TV, Sky Sports,
Sky Q. On the next layer, we've
got content delivery networks.
Obviously, there's many of them.
We've got video
workflow with Harmonic.
We've got core services layer.
So this is a sort of wrapper.
We'll see that on
the next slide.
We're using Jenkins.
The sort of ketchup bottle
is what we call Sauce.
Sauce is our configuration
management tool
that we've written in-house.
We're using Prometheus.
We've got Grafana.
We've got Puppet
for orchestration.
We've got ELK Stack for
logging and information.
We've got container
and orchestration
with Docker Engine
and Kubernetes.
We do run our own
Kubernetes cluster.
We're not using
GKE at the moment.
And, really, what
I would call out
as the only difference
is the bottom layer.
So you've got on-premise
infrastructure,
your typical Intel Xeon
processors, et cetera,
that cost you a lot of money and
generally go out to date pretty
quickly because the upgrade
cycle on servers is pretty
fast--
12 to 18 months.
And then on the bottom layer
on the right-hand side,
you've got a bunch
of cloud stuff--
hence we being here.
So we'll go through.
We've got Google Compute
Engine, which we're using.
We've got Google Cloud
Storage, Google Load Balancing,
Cloud Router because
we're dealing with video.
We need to reliably get
the video to the cloud,
not trusting the internet.
Could use the internet.
That's possible.
But you want to take a more
reliable approach to it.
So using Google Direct Connect,
having redundant 10-gig links
delivering multiple
channels into the cloud
is the sensible way to go.
You need firewalls there because
you need to protect your data.
And you've got NAT and the
entire access management--
to name but a few.
And really, that's the
only difference there,
is that bottom infrastructure.
So what does single-channel
fault domain look like?
So I've got an example here
with Formula One channel.
So I appreciates it's a
little bit busy diagram.
So working through, from the
top, in the blue box of the top
there, we've got SDS, top layer.
It managers live
channel configuration.
That's the YAML files
and stuff that I
was talking about before--
your 5 meg, your 4 meg, your
3 meg, your 2 meg, your 1 meg,
your half meg.
When you A/B a ladder for
customers, your protocols,
your edge list, your
Smooth, your DASH.
DRM types and stuff because
you're a paid TV operator.
And it also manages
capacity, as well.
So we were in our own
Kubernetes cluster.
And so we managed
the capacity on it
to make sure that we
have enough resources
to be able to deliver the
video at the right time,
in the right place.
It also manages the
metrics, as well.
So it's pulling all that in.
And what it's doing-- it's
aggregating the metrics
from the whole stack.
So this is
everything, basically,
coming in from the left-hand
side to the right-hand side.
It's also pulling in the
client-side metrics, as well.
So you actually get
an end-to-end view,
which is really, really
cool for operations people
because generally,
they often complain
they don't have
enough information,
or they don't have
the right information.
So trying to fix that and
give them that visibility
is really key.
The purple box on
the left hand side--
it says, SDS video and
quality monitoring.
So its purpose is to monitor
the output of the mezzanine.
So this is your input
into your transcoder.
That's comparing 1080
sources coming, comparing
against the output,
which is what
the customers are consuming.
So they might be gaining
1080 outputs, 720, 506,
so on and so forth.
So this is really key-- and
I mentioned it earlier--
because you want to
make sure that you're
putting good video out, that
you're not dropping frames,
that you're not having lip
sync issues, for example.
So that's quite critical.
And then you've got the
other green box, there,
which is harmonic content prep.
What I would call
out here is really--
do you see there's a
gray box in the middle?
It says, availability zone 1.
And then it's surrounded by--
it's a little bit hard to make
out on this big screen, here.
But there's four boxes there.
There's transcode,
package and storage.
There's encryption
and origin server.
What you'll notice is,
there's a little Google
Cloud in the middle there.
As we've seen in
Melika's diagram,
before, Google Cloud is
a lot bigger than that.
But I couldn't fit
it on the screen.
And then below, you've
got availability zone 2.
Really key is that
we're doing this-- this
is highly available streaming.
So in the normal world, we're
only just doing the top layer.
And that's how we've been doing
it for the last 10 years or so.
The innovation, really,
has come around being
able to do it in parallel.
So you've got two parallel
streams coming in.
So if you work
through the example
from the left-hand side,
you have mezzanine output
going over the Google Direct
Connect that I talked about.
That's 10 gigabits redundant,
coming from two different data
centers, coming
into a transcoder.
At the transcoder,
you've got this--
you see the blue
and the red arrows?
You're coming in and
there's a black arrow
in between the transcoders.
This is synchronization.
I show it in the yellow
box below, where it says,
frame accurate synchronization.
And frame accurate
is actually key,
because if you want to
put advertising on here,
you need to make sure
that it's frame accurate.
Package and storage formats--
your HLS, your Smooth,
your DASH--
you need to also be
synchronized there.
So you need to have a protocol
that basically says, I'm here.
I'm here.
Make sure that it's the
same, because otherwise,
on the right-hand
side where it says
active active live
synchronized content, and then
with the little
sort of globe there,
you can't do something funky
like go AZ1, AZ2, AZ1, AZ2.
get Because you notice
those two red arrows allows
us to load balance live
content concurrently.
And actually, I think
Moore is going to give you
a little demo of that later.
So here, we're
actually seeing that we
can use both legs in parallel.
These are in two different
availability zones.
So what it should say
there is that they're
in the same region.
So if we deployed this--
let's use the US example.
We're west coast now.
So we went to Google's
region in US west coast.
And we deployed this here.
We're putting it into
one AZ and a second AZ.
So this means that if
the AZ had an issue, then
there is another one available
to provide customers.
So you've got redundancy
both at data-center level,
within the availability zones,
but also at a channel level
because, going back
to my earlier example,
channel density was all
around, how many channels
can I fit into this server here?
So if buy the most
expensive server,
usual economics works out that
I can get more channels on it.
Problem is that the fault
domain of that channel
is the number of
channels you can get.
So if you can get five channels
on it and that box gets broken,
then five channels are affected.
You have, now, an outage.
Go back to my example
about software upgrades.
Software upgrades come
out every few months.
They might fix bugs.
They might introduce features.
But when it happens, you're
going to take up five channels.
And then this
happens quite a lot.
So we're trying to avoid that.
So on my next slide--
I've just talked previously
about happy path, when
everything's working great.
So what happens when
something goes wrong?
Because we can't assume
that everything is great.
I've got something's
gone red here.
This is in availability zone 1.
My packager has gone wrong.
I don't really know-- perhaps
it's just this example--
why that's happened.
I don't really care, actually.
What I care about is
the customer experience.
So the customers on the-- excuse
me-- on the right-hand side
must carry on working.
They must keep on
serving the CDNs.
They must keep filling
up the customer claims
buffer on the playback.
And it must be consistent.
So don't interrupt that
customer experience.
So the way that you go
about this, in this example,
is two things happen.
Firstly is that you need
to detect there's a fault.
So in the bottom box here, the
packager in AZ1 has failed.
And so this means a
loss of resilience,
not a loss of channel.
And that's a big distinction
because you're still on air.
You're still making money.
And you're not getting
customer tickets.
Customer's not going to call
the call center to say, hey,
I've just noticed you
had a loss of resilience,
because they can still
watch "Game of Thrones"
or the football or something.
So the second thing you need
to do, on the right-hand side,
is, you see there's a red x
there where there previously
was an arrow.
You need to be able to make sure
that you stop sending traffic
to the broken leg.
So in here, my example
in availability zone 1,
that leg is gone.
Basically, it's not updating.
So the manifest is not updating.
There's no fresh video
because the packager
is no longer outputting video.
So therefore, it
can't be encrypted.
Therefore, it can't be
delivered by Origim's server.
And go back to my example.
AZ1 bad, AZ2 good.
That model doesn't work.
That's a bad
customer experience.
What you need to do is make sure
that you're only going to AZ2.
So it's AZ2, AZ2, AZ2, AZ2,
because the other leg is fine.
It's operationally good.
Now the way that we've
solved this problem
is, Kubernetes will do,
obviously, the monitoring.
It will detect and rebuild that
the packager in AZ1 has failed.
I'll go and refer
you back to what
I was talking about
a few minutes ago
with the YAML files.
The YAML files are the state
of the file of the channel.
So in the Sky
Sports 1 example, we
can return it back to how
it was 30 minutes ago,
before the fault occurred.
So we don't know
why it's happened.
What we're trying to do
is restore that service
as quickly as we
can and put it back
to how it was 30 minutes ago.
Once we've done that and
the health checks pass
and the channel
resilience is restored,
we actually go back
to the previous slide,
where it's now in AZ1.
It's actually working again.
And that's, obviously,
really cool.
I'll just call out the bottom
things on the encryption.
There's a pay TV operator.
We have digital
rights management--
so the things like Play Ready,
Widevine, other DRMs, et
cetera.
And Origin, obviously, is
storing out and encrypted.
The tools that we
use to do this,
to actually recover service--
obviously, we operate our
own Kubernetes cluster.
In the two AZs, we have
independent clusters.
So the one in AZ1 is
independent of AZ2.
So we run them in parallel.
And we're doing the same
workload in parallel, twice.
We're using Source.
Source is something
that we wrote
ourself, which is our
configuration management tool.
And it basically goes
and manages that.
So we use, obviously,
things like Git repos.
And when an engineer
wants to make changes--
for example, they have to check
in and they have to check out.
We've got version
control on it, as well.
And I don't have a slide on
it, but from a confidence point
of view, we actually go
through five different realms
on all our paths to production.
We go through a
development cycle.
So we have a
development environment.
We go through a
test environment.
We go through a non-functional
test environment,
where we're injecting load.
And we go through a
stage, which is all
about testing and making
sure that it's reliable,
because it's very
important in video.
It's no good if it stays up
for 24 hours and falls over.
You need it to
run for two weeks.
And then, obviously,
in production--
show what you're doing.
The one of the things
that I will just finish on
is, when we talk to
Sky Sports about this,
we went through the
economics of the cloud.
One of the things
that was called out
was, we did the number
crunching on it,
and they had a system
that they've had
operational for eight years.
And when we went
through and said, look,
that hardware is no
longer supported.
We can't get spare parts.
We can't get software
upgrades for it.
We need to go and replace that.
So we came out, and
it was a big number.
It was a high six-figure number.
When we went through
them and said, look,
how often do you
actually use that system?
Because the Formula One's
only on once every other week.
The football's on
several times a week.
What do you do at this time of
day when there's no football on
and there's no Formula One?
Well, it's just sat there.
Well, maybe that's not the
cost-effective way to do it.
So we asked them, how many hours
of programming do you have?
It turned out to be about
1,000 hours of programming
per year for various events.
And we said, well,
surely there's
got to be more cost-effective
way of doing it.
Could we consider
an opex-type thing
and move those
workloads to the cloud?
And so we did that.
And it is significant savings.
It's less than half the cost.
And it's more flexible.
And we don't have
all those pain points
that we talked about before.
We don't have to worry
about infrastructure.
That's Google's problem.
We don't have to worry
about storage, for example.
That's Google's problem.
Load balancing-- it's
Google's problem.
Part of the-- there we go.
Thank you.
I'm overtime.
MOORE MACAULEY: Hello, everyone.
Thank you, Jeff.
Thank you for a very
interesting presentation.
You get to enjoy another accent.
I'm originally from Ireland.
And I'm going to try and speak
very slowly, because I've
got a tendency, when I'm
nervous in front of big crowds,
to speak awfully quickly.
Thank you very much.
So I'm from Harmonic.
And we believe in smarter,
faster, simpler video
streaming.
And we were very excited to be
involved with Sky and Google
on this project.
Just a little bit of
background on who Harmonic are.
Some of you may never
have heard of us,
although I'm sure
that over the years,
you've watched
video that's flowed
through many of our devices.
We've been around
for over 20 years.
We are headquartered
in Silicon Valley.
If you happen to
drive along the 237,
we're about North First Street.
Around the world, we have over
5,000 customers in the media
and service provider sector.
We started off
building appliances.
And if we look at the number
of over-the-top channels
we have deployed, we
entered the streaming market
about when Jeff
did, many years ago.
We have 38,000 live
channels deployed today.
Most of those channels are
deployed on appliances.
But many of them are now
deployed in our software,
as a service offering.
In fact, if I look at our
software as a service offering,
for our customers, we
actually deliver video
from our origin servers to over
6.5 million subscribers who
pay those customers
of ours every month
for the video services
that they watch.
Subscription video
is really difficult.
As Jeff has described, you
have to provide a really
high quality of service.
And our goal these days
is really to make sure
that we maximize that
quality of experience
for our customer's customers.
So how did we do that?
How did we make the transition
from what was effectively
a box manufacturer in
Silicon Valley to someone
who provides a software
as a service offering?
It was no small change.
But as the product
architect, it was my job,
six years ago, to kick
off a project that
looked at everything Harmonic
did for its customers
from end to end and
to think about how
we could re-envisage that
from a hardware delivery
to a software delivery.
For customers, we take
care of many things.
We take care of
ingesting content.
We take care of play out,
graphics, transcoding,
over the top.
Even into the traditional cable
world and satellite world,
we provide statistical
multiplexing solutions.
We encrypt the content.
We package it.
We provide origin serving
functionality, manifest
manipulation, and monitoring.
And there was a
very traditional way
of delivering that in
the appliance world--
very simple in terms of boxes
delivering functionality.
Everybody understood
exactly how it was deployed.
What we needed to do was,
we needed to think about it,
reinvent it.
Reinvent it and
deliver something that
has a different architecture.
It's based on containers.
And think about all
of those problems
that you have described.
How do you effectively provide
one-for-one resilience?
How do you provide
upgradability?
And we did that in
a product that we
called VOS, which is our
cloud-native media processing
platform.
And it's what Jeff used.
And we also deliver that
as a SAS offering, vOS 360,
to our customers.
When I look at Sky,
Sky gave me all
of the usual requirements
that anyone starts off
with a live project.
They really wanted to hit all
of the devices they needed
to use, all of the
streaming formats,
to make sure they got
into those devices.
Closed captioning.
They need timed metadata
because they were doing sports.
You want to be able to know
that a goal has gone off,
send notifications.
And they really wanted
ease of installation,
ease of monitoring,
and ease of recovery.
This is what I hear
from every customer.
But what was different
about Sky's requirements
was that desire to
make it better, that
no single point of failure.
And although Jeff
didn't mention it,
he also put a second
constraint on it, which was he
didn't want any additional
delay to his sports.
Because, you know what?
We could have built a very,
very redundant system, but if we
had delayed another 30 seconds.
But he said no.
Don't want any more
delay to my sports.
They need to be
faster, not slower.
So that made it a
little bit harder.
I think we've been 45 minutes
into this presentation.
And it's time you
saw some video.
But before I do, I'm just
going to show you one diagram.
This is the diagram
of the video that I'm
going to show you, how
we put it together.
We deployed it on Google Cloud.
We went a little bit
farther than Jeff asked for.
We put it in separate
zones, not just
separate availability zones.
And we used GKE, not GCP,
because I like it when Google
deploys Kubernetes for me.
Like Jeff said, I don't want
to worry about that, either.
We built this system.
Let's see what
that A/B switching
looks like from a
customer standpoint.
So here's some
beautiful content.
And while you watch
the beautiful content,
it does say it's in 4K and HDR.
And although I'm standing
in a theater today,
I'm really sorry to
tell you what you're
watching isn't in 4K and HDR.
I wish that it was.
However, if at home you
would love to see it
and you happen to have
a Roku streaming device,
there is a NASA channel on
the Roku streaming device
that we provide the
back end for that
will allow you to see this
same content in 4K and HDR.
And breathtaking as
the content is here,
it's even more
breathtaking there.
While you've been
watching the video,
perhaps you've
noticed the VOS 360
logo bopping back and
forward from the left
and right to the screen.
That wasn't put there
by a professional.
That was put there
by me, which is why
it's so accurately positioned.
So what I did,
actually, was I went
into those two
transcoding instances
that Jeff showed you previously.
And I configured
one of them to put
the logo on the left
side and the other one
to put the logo
on the right side.
A little bit of a difference.
And so that's why you get
to see it popping back
and forward from either side.
But it is beautiful
content, and I
do encourage you to go
and have a look at it.
I'm a great believer in NASA.
I love it.
And I love the
content they produce.
Some of the moon rises
are amazing to watch.
We did go even further than
just zone 1 and zone 2.
We offer our software
not just as a SAS.
I told you, we sold it
to customers on premise.
So here is another diagram
where you could actually
do that same synchronization
with an on-premise cluster
and a cluster in GCP or GKE.
I think we actually did
deliver on what Sky wanted.
And the challenge that
we really had to solve
was this challenge
called the CAP Theorem,
or Brewer's Theorem, for
the computer scientists.
Among you, we already
know what it is.
For those of us who don't
understand, basically,
if we partition two things
and we drop information
between them, then we have
to make a decision about
whether or not we
serve every request.
And sometimes, the
requests are different.
Or we only serve
requests from one side
when we know there are problems.
We don't want the video
to jump back and forward.
It's got to look seamless,
like it did here.
So we sacrifice in availability.
And the whole challenge was to
make your availability numbers
for that backup system
as high as possible.
That delivered Sky benefits.
It gave them the
improved false tolerance.
It gave them the ability
to do green-blue upgrades.
to do A/B testing.
Way more than we
originally thought.
Often, we started off
looking at the fault
tolerance of this project.
I think, as Harmonic
in this project,
we really did deliver
smarter, faster,
simpler video streaming.
And it's working with
customers like Sky
and working with
people like Google that
enables us to deliver
on some of the most
fantastic projects in the
world with some of the greatest
content--
Formula One, NASA.
It's a great place to be.
Melika, do you have a
question for both of us?
Or are we out of time?
MELIKA GOLKARAM: I
think we're out of time.
MOORE MACAULEY: All right.
Well, I don't get to
answer a question.
Thank you very much, indeed.
Thank you, Melika.
Thank you, Jeff.
It's been great to be here.
I hope you enjoyed it.
[APPLAUSE]